ومن مدينه سرمدا شمال ادلب ينضم الينا
منير المصطفى نائب مدير الدفاع المدنيه
السوري مرحبا بك على شاشه العربيه نريد
الاستناد الى اخر الاحصائيات انتم تغدون
وسائل الاعلام على مدى الساعه باخر
الارقام يمكن ان تضعنا في اخر الارقام
لديك
نعم شكرا لك وللاخوه المشاهدين جميعا في
الحقيقه يعني اوقات عصيبه سباق حقيقي مع
الزمن يقوم به عناصر الفوز البيضاء في
شمال غربي سوريا من اجل سحب العالقين من
تحت الانقاض وهم احياء لانه اول 72 ساعه
من اي كارثه مثل هذه الكوارثيه تعتبر جدا
مهمه من اجل ان ننقذ ما يمكن انقاذه من
الاحياء من تحت الانقاب حتى هذه اللحظه
استطاعت فريق الفوز البيضاء ان انتشال ما
يقارب 1640 حاله وفاه من تحت الانقاض
واستطاعت تقديم مساعده لاكثر من 2700 مصاب
تم انتشالهم
نعم رجع الارقام
1640 حاله وفاه
انا اتكلم عن منطقه شمال غرب سوريا مناطق
خارج سيطره مناطق النظام مناطق النظام
تعطي احصائيات مستقله اما انا اعطي
الاحصائيات في مناطق خارج سيطره نظام
الاسد
1640 حاله وفاه حتى اللحظه في شمال غرب
سوريا طب ماذا عن الناجين
الناجين 2006 حاله من الناجين او المصابين
الذين تم انتشالهم وهم احياء من تحت
الانقاض طبعا وهم الان في المشافي ويتلقون
العلاج
الصور التي قمتم ببثها منذ قليل على
شاشتكم الكريمه يعني بعض من هذه الصور هي
من شمال غرب سوريا هي في مناطق ادلب
ومناطق جننترس والمناطق خارج سيطره النظام
ليست من داخل منطقه النظام كل الصور التي
تحوي متطوعين الخواز البيضاء هي من مناطق
شمال غرب سوريا وهذه المنطقه هي التي نالت
الحظ الوافر من الانهيارات والحد الوافر
من الدمار اكثر من المناطق الاخرى للاسف
نسال الله يعني ان يتقبل جميع الموتى
اللهم امين يا سؤال وهو المتعلق برصد شبكه
مرا العربيه على الارض اللي اصوات من
الناجين تحت الانقاض وهم يصرخون وهم
يطلبون الاغاثه وهناك تحركات من قبل بعض
فرق الانقاذ هل من جديد في هذا الامر
نعم حتى الان لازلنا نسمع اصوات من تحت
الانقاض تاتي يعني لا زال هناك بعض
الموجودين تحت هذه الانقراض هم على قيد
الحياه فرقنا تعمل وبقوه وبدون اي توقف
منذ يعني وقوع هذه الكارثه حتى هذه اللحظه
يوصل عدد ساعات العمل تجاوز ال 65 ساعه
عمل حتى الان لا يوجد اي اي احد من مطوعين
البيضاء الذي يصل عددهم حتى 2800 متطوع لا
يوجد اي احد منهم الا موجود ضمن احد نقاط
العمل عمليات البحث جاريه السباق مع الزمن
جاري الامكانيات للاسف نقطه المساعدات هل
اي مساعدات وصلت اليكم انتم تقومون بمجهود
كبير الدفاع المدني السوري في هذه المناطق
يقوم بمجهود كبير هل وصل اليكم اي مساعدات
اي دعم خارجي ام انكم تعتمدون فقط على بعض
المنظمات الموجوده على الارض منذ قبل هذه
الكارثه
حتى هذه اللحظه لا يوجد اي مساعدات وصلت
من جهات خارجيه او من منظمات دوليه الى
منطقه شمال غرب سوريا
الجهود المبذوله هي جهود فرق الدفاع
المدني وهي جهود المدنيين المتواجدون داخل
هذه المناطق من اجل سحب العالقين من تحت
الانقراض لا يوجد اي مساعدات لا مساعدات
يعني وصلت مساعدات عينيه من اليات ولا من
معدات ولا اي شيء وصل حتى الان عبر
المعابر المتصله من تركيا ولا حتى عبر
المعابر الموجوده مع نظام الاسد يقولون ان
المعبر معبر باب الهوى مفتوح وان هناك
اتصالات لفتح معبر السلام والرعي هل هناك
اي مؤشرات تقول ان هذه المعابر يمكن ان
تعمل خلال الساعات القليله القادمه لضمان
وصول المساعدات والدعم لكم
في الحقيقه منذ الساعه الخامسه من مساء
البارحه هذه المعابر كانت جاهزه وكانت
تعمل وهناك العديد من الضحايا الذين سقطوا
على الارض التركيه من السوريين يدخلون عبر
هذه المعابر وهذا يعني ان المعابر مفتوحه
بالكامل ان الطرقات المؤديه الى المعابر
مفتوحه كون هذه الجثث تصل الى سوريا وتم
استلامها من ذويها ودفنها في الداخل
السوري في شمال غرب سوريا نحن نتوقع ان
شاء الله يعني
في الغد ان يكون هناك يعني وصول لجزء من
هذه المساعدات الموعودين فيها موعدين
بوصولها الى شمال غرب سوريا ولكن حتى
تاريخ اللحظه يعني نحن وصلنا الى 65 ساعه
عمل متواصل وهي اهم ساعات عمل في بدايه
هذا السؤال الاخير باختصار المعدات التي
تعتمدون عليها في جهود الانقاذ هل تساعدكم
هل هي غير كافيه لكارثه من هذا النوع
اجابه قصيره اذا سمحت
حقيقه يوجد لدينا جزء من المعدات ولكن هي
غير كافيه هي غير مؤهله حتى تستجيب لكارثه
من هذا النوع هذه الكارثه تحتاج الى تدخل
دولي مباشر حتى حتى تستطيع ان مثل هذه
المساعده من سرمدا شمال ادلب منير المصطفى
نائب مدير الدفاع المدني السوري شكرا لك
على مشاركتنا لهذه المعلومات ونتمنى لكم
التوفيق في هذه الجهود المبذوله